for more than a hundred years many feel
it's been America's most famous Speedway
not a man-made track a racecourse but a
part of nature
the famous Bonneville Salt Flats the
salt that stretches for miles and miles
in Northwest Utah makes the place look
like a different planet one that is
uniquely suited to making vehicles go
very very fast some of the most
cherished land speed records in the
world have been targeted and broken
since they started racing at Bonneville
before World War one
but today the salt that is essential to
racing is going away and a bitter debate
is raging over how that should be
handled
we arrived at the flats before dawn the
piece at Sunday sunrise a stark contrast
to the blast of adrenaline that followed
busy loud ridiculously fast amateur
racers and their families have been
coming to the Bonneville Speedway for
generations this is your dad's fire suit
yeah that's a little big it works
including Olivia nish just nineteen what
is it about racing for you and racing
here it's a rush it's godly to be honest
it's family yeah they race trucks
motorcycles streamliners and more
sometimes it speeds of more than 500
miles an hour
[Music]
the racing here began in 1912 but really
picked up in the 1930s with the rise of
hot rods modified Model T's and their
successors AB Jenkins the so called
father of the Bonneville Salt Flats
held more records than any other sports
driver in the world and here comes AB
Jenkins the Marmon meet er down goes the
flag and this great speed run is
underway simple vehicles amped up by
greasers to hit knee knockin speeds
racing works here because thousands of
years ago a body of water the size of
Lake Michigan evaporated boxed in by
surrounding mountains the salt that was
left behind moist and cool allows tires
to grip and not overheat but the salt at
Bonneville is changing
I tell people anytime you want to know
what it feels like to go to another
planet you go to the Bonneville Salt
Flats Dennis Sullivan is president of
the Utah Salt Flats racing Association I
don't think that the general public
realizes that this place is being taken
away and I'm gonna use the word raping
of the Bonneville Salt Flats you think
the Bonneville Salt Flats are being
raped I think they are that's a hell of
a strong word to use who do you think is
responsible we blame the people that
gave the leases we think they were so
poorly done that it took all the salt
away you're blaming the government I'm
blaming the BLM the Bureau of Land
Management oversees the Salt Flats for
the federal government's more than 50
years ago they made deals with mining
companies who use this land to get
potash a fertilizer the process requires
separating out the salt from the potash
but the Racing Association says the
leases don't require putting the
leftover salt back Kevin Oliver is the
Utah West manager for the BLM Dennis
Sullivan says the BLM and I quote is
allowing the land to be raped you know
that's his quote he owns it he can speak
to that what do you think when you hear
that I don't think much I think I know
that we don't allow the land to be rape
that's what I know
the Racing Association says the top
layer of salt was once four feet thick
and is now in most places down to one
inch
the BLM for their part acknowledges a 7%
decrease of the crust package over the
last decade and a half is there a
solution here that makes everyone happy
I mean I think that's what they're
working towards right now
Brenda Bowen is a scientist who's been
studying the salt flats what has your
work shown so far is happening here our
work has shown that over the last 30
years or so the footprints are the 2d
surface of salt that's here in this
landscape has been decreasing Bowen
showed us the current state of the
terrain by the way it is nothing more
than what's on your dinner table this is
like tables just millions and millions
of shakers stretched out over a changing
landscape less of it on the speedway the
racing community says all that salt has
ended up here up to 250 million tons of
it just a couple thousand feet away from
the tracks remnants from all that mining
and they want 50 million dollars to put
it back when I first came out here we
never signed bumps it was flat like a
billiard table Louise knoweth is a long
time automotive journalist who was now
spokesperson for save the salt a
non-profit group that ones the speedway
replenished she's also a former racer
which makes her mission personal why
should we pay for this to fix it because
America
was built on hopes and dreams and
they're killing the dreams
that's how rooted how deep it is it is
these are ordinary people doing
extraordinary things every one of these
is hand-built
every every expression I'm gonna have
the fastest air-cooled bug VW I'm going
to have the fastest Chevrolet I'm gonna
have the fastest hotrod in the world
while all of this runs its course Brenda
Bowens work continues you believe that
the combination of factors that leads to
less salt on the track yes those factors
include what the mining an extraction
that's been going on for about a hundred
years it also includes changes in
environmental conditions and then also
lend us and how we're manipulating the
landscape you know with roads going
through and the racers on the surface we
reached out to the mining company
intrepid potash they declined our
request for an on-camera interview but
said there now voluntarily returning
hundreds of thousands of tons of salt
every year the Racing Association says
it's not enough they also told us they
believe any effect the racers are having
on the salt is negligible in comparison
what should happen here I would say
leave it alone for a few years don't
come out here don't drive on it when
it's wet give it a minute and let's see
where it gets to you know that's a
non-starter no pun intended for the
racing community I mean it's not a
racetrack in a you know warehouse it's
not an indoor environment its nature
Olivia nish the first female driver in
her family's three generations of racing
at Bonneville hit a hundred and fifty
five miles an hour on her first run the
weekend we visited before spinning out
while attempting to hit 180 on run
number two she plans to be back for many
many more it is disappointing to see but
we just make the best of what we have
and
drive right generation to drive yeah
right and that's what I'm hoping cuz we
were talking about that earlier is if it
would stay here for a long time I think
it will but it's been here for thousands
of years why not thousand more
Brenda Bowen the scientist we talked to
has a visit a very difficult position
difficult job she's trying to navigate
between the racers the miners and the
government all of whom have different
interests in all this nowhere else in
the u.s. they were they can race like
that Bolivia in Australia
internationally but nowhere else in the
US can you find a place like the
Bonneville Salt Flats do the racers
acknowledge that wear and tear on the
salt well I think they would say that
any effect that they may have is
negligible in comparison to what they
think mining and other things do right